que ce soit dans le monde d'harry potter
ou aux clayes-sous-bois contacter
vitesse sont les meilleurs atouts du
quidditch comme dans la saga on retrouve
les poursuiveurs les batteurs chargé des
cognacs et le gardien joueurs de
quidditch dans une équipe de l'essonne
gilles décide de créer aux
clayes-sous-bois un club les hedge-funds
au mois de juillet le quidditch ça
serait un mélange de rugby avec pour le
contacter deux enfants pas sages de vol
et de cardio parce qu'on voit courir
donc lé batteur dont qui en fait c'est
des gens qui ont un ballon qui a pour
taper dessus pour taper sur les autres
doivent lever le ballon et le ballet de
son boucher et repartir cage plusieurs
apprentis joueurs sont venus découvrir
cette activité
au programme un échauffement
entraînement à la passe et prise en main
du ballet vient ensuite la séance des
tirs au but d'abord avec un batteur puis
avec le gardien essayer de rester sur
son balai et puis essayer surtout de
tirer avec une certaine précision ce
qu'on a trois sert soda différentes
hauteurs avisés et tout en étant en
mouvement et avec le ballon entre les
jambes donc c'est vrai que c'est assez
c'est assez stratégie qui est assez
compliquée je pense que c'est un sport
qui est vraiment cardio déjà ça change
c'est pas de la course de fond
c'est vraiment cardio avec pas mal
d'allers retours c'est vraiment
intéressant dans le sens où il ya
plusieurs rôles
premier rendez vous pour le club des
clayes-sous-bois les 18 et 19 novembre à
limoges pour la coupe de france de
quidditch